welcome to jurassic world in real life
let's bring back some of the most
dangerous creatures to ever roam the
earth
what could go wrong
right
how would we be able to clone dinosaurs
what would life with them roaming the
earth be like
and which ones would eat you for
breakfast first
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we brought dinosaurs back from
extinction
in the book and subsequent movie saga of
jurassic park
scientists find dna from dinosaur blood
preserved inside of a fossilized
mosquito
then they clone a whole theme park's
worth of prehistoric creatures
and of course all hell breaks loose
what you might not know is that the
story was inspired by real life events
in 1982 scientists discovered a 40
million year old fly
mummified in amber
and that's where the nonfiction drama
ends and author michael crichton's
science fiction begins
but it's not the only discovery that has
raised the question of whether you could
bring dinosaurs back from extinction
components of dinosaur blood were
discovered in a fossilized mosquito from
the eocene epoch
but there wasn't any dinosaur dna that
we could use for cloning
dna is a vulnerable thing it could be
deteriorated by sunlight or water
so far the oldest dna discovered is 1
million years old
so
if you want to clone dinosaurs you'd
need to find dna at least 66 times older
than that
instead of waiting on the miraculous
discovery of dinosaur dna
let's try something different
like genetically reverse engineering
dinosaurs
you could take an animal that's alive
today and work backward
okay so going back through 66 million
years of evolution wouldn't be a walk in
the park
genetically engineering a chicken to
have teeth or a long tail
wouldn't exactly make it a dinosaur
life uh finds a way
now if your dinosaur creations somehow
escaped your maximum security lab
and began living in the wild
you should be ready for trouble
with over 700 different dinosaur species
discovered worldwide
you'd have to find out which of them
would be safest to share the planet with
and which ones would pose a serious
threat
and you'd have to figure that out the
hard way
they would breed on their own
they'd be hunted for sport
or for meat
maybe even kept as pets
and then there would be a tyrannosaurus
rex on the prowl for you
well no not specifically you
humans in general
people would spend less time outdoors
out of fear of velociraptor attacks
jobs requiring travel would become
infinitely more dangerous
do you want to be driving an 18-wheeler
with one of these things running across
the highway
travel would also be more expensive
because of extra security precautions
delays and cancellations would be common
due to the flight patterns of
pterodactyls
and food supply chains would be
disrupted as cattle and other livestock
would be prime targets for predatory
dinosaurs
these creatures never had mammals to
snack on in the past ranches and farms
would be like a buffet for them
massive herbivores like sauropods would
struggle to meet their dietary needs
the plants that currently exist wouldn't
be the same as those millions of years
ago
sauropods wouldn't have teeth jaws or
digestive systems adapted to eating the
grasses that are common today
other animals and living things
would need to adapt to the new predators
on the block
dinosaurs would be the ultimate invasive
species
and their presence could cause
extinction events for some of today's
species
it wouldn't be a bed of roses for the
dinosaurs either
unless they were engineered to be
adapted to our modern day global
environments and climate
they would struggle too
during the cretaceous period the
atmosphere had 14 percent more oxygen
than ours does today
for dinosaurs it would feel like they
were suddenly living at a mount everest
base camp
if you could bring dinosaurs back
you'd be facing a major ethical dilemma
mother nature wiped them out
reintroducing them for pure
entertainment
would be a hard case to win against
scientists pushing for further
conservation efforts
especially if you're planning to open
your very own jurassic park lots of
people would want to enjoy the dinosaurs
in a zoo-like setting
you could stand to make a lot of money
so you'd likely have more luck
convincing people if you stick to
research purposes
you could do it to further cloning
technology or to verify findings and
theories based on fossilized remains
maybe you'd be better off bringing back
an animal that became extinct because of
humans
but
that's a story
for another
what if i i i
i i